wir haben einfach nur das hier das ist
alles was wir haben in dieser verdammten
welt wir haben nur dass hier wir haben
hier einen kleinen sondern weil sie
nicht anders immer so ein pokemon soweit
ihr so eine große insel ist dabei
meistens unseren wettkampf drauf und
dann waren da noch ein paar kleine
inseln wo man dann immer ein bisschen
pause machen könnte wenn man damit
surfer darüber geflogen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer minecraft sieht vorstellung in der
1.7.2008 ich hab das bei der 1.6 schon
am anfang gemacht dass ich ab nun jeden
tag eine vorstellung machen werde bis
mir so erstmal nicht ausgehen aber bis
ich auf jeden fall die geilsten erst mal
vorgestellt habe was würdet ihr davon
halten wir jetzt morgen das sieht
vorstellung kommt dann übermorgen auch
und das ganze dann irgendwie weiß ich
nicht eine woche lang oder so bis halt
die geilsten stil zu mehr oder weniger
vorgestellt habe die ich am geilsten
finde und danach werden wir wieder so
normal manchmal passiert vorstellung
kommen also was haltet ihr davon dann
gebt einfach mal daumen hoch wenn ihr
wollt dass ich so was macht ihr könnt
noch sieht es in die kommentare
schreiben
und zwar der titel nicht euch heute
vorstellen ist ein nein ich habe nicht
gewusst dass wir alles total
professionell ist ein zweifel zieht und
zwar könne er einfach diesen zieht ein
geben dass es - 53 87 21 29 52 03 39 01
24 kann man sich natürlich locker sie
merken
neue werte welt erstellen ich glaub ich
hab blut gehustet schmeckt auf jeden
fall noch blut die welt geladen ist
sollte eine 1.7 immer ein bisschen
länger den ganzen scheiß million
allerdings braucht man gar nicht viel
biome oasen die tintenfische überall und
zwar ist es einfach ein richtig geiler
survival zieht
ich habe dann einfach so entdeckt als
ich manchmal welten erstellen wollte um
eine stunde fürs video zu finden habe
ich noch einfacher und screenshots
gefunden
und wir haben einfach nein ich möchte
nicht die kag minecraft musik
entschuldigung später aus machen danke
wir haben einfach nur das hier das ist
alles was wir haben in dieser verdammten
welt wir haben nur dass hier wir haben
hier so einen kleinen so eine gesonderte
sondern
weil sie nicht hat das immer so ein
pokemon soweit hier eine große insel ist
dabei meistens so einem wettkampf auf
und dann waren da noch ein paar kleine
inseln wo man dann immer ein bisschen
pause machen könnte wenn man dann mit
surfer dann ist man wieder über geflogen
dann irgendwie hier so und dann ist man
dann irgendwie hier auf einer insel
rentiert halt noch mal so eine kleine
insel und ich hab das jetzt alles kaputt
gemacht ich brauche das meer hinaus und
lokal am afrika-cup ob gamma ray so also
da wir so ein oder hinten geht's auch
noch weiter geht noch weiter dahin haben
wir noch paar kleine inselchen oder
geht's zur allgemeinen festland weiter
nee nee ich glaube nicht doch
doch doch das ist einfach nur ein
bisschen eine größere insel alter ich
glaube das ist einfach nur eine größere
insel oder wo das ist wirklich festland
doch es sieht schon herr ich denke mal
so wenn das dann hier so rum geht das
ist dann hier umgeht das ist einfach so
eine insel sondern riesige aber sonst
wir wollen uns eigentlich da hinten
darauf fokussieren uns was das hier
scheiß egal da ist übrigens so ein
cooles mädchen drin das jedoch ganz geil
aus und hier ist auch so ein richtig
geiler strandliege du könntest du hier
perfekten häuschen bauen und dann haben
wir so ein bisschen im pool und so
perfekt also richtig geil aber wir
wollen und sich darauf konzentrieren
sondern wir wollen uns auf das
konzentriert was erkenntnis und zwar den
survival sieht und zwar kann man hier
einfach mit den zieht ein gebt versucht
doch einfach mal auf dieser insel so zu
überleben und falls nicht dann könnte es
playhouse machen keine ahnung was er
daraus machen wollte jedenfalls hat mir
haben wir da halt so ein paar was ist
das ist ein paar reichen beispielsweise
ausreichen
die haben wir zum beispiel ein paar
reichen ein paar normale bäumchen also
nicht allzu viel aber auf jeden fall
genug um sich dann vernünftigen wald
anzulegen hühnchen haben wir auch ich
glaube sogar noch mehr als dieses eine
also vorhin war noch ein paar mehr kann
man das ding woanders sind ich glaube
wir haben sogar eine höhle irgendwo also
ich weiß nicht ob es einen speziellen
eingang zu der höhle gibt aber ich habe
auf jeden fall da sind noch mehr hühner
überall ich habe auf jeden fall ein paar
zombies gehört am tag wir können uns
einfach mal so ein bisschen ein graben
einmal meisten sind in so bergen
wirklich
die gehören drin und gott darf ich das
laute mensch sie da wir perfekt gefahren
alles isst viel salat
ich weiß nicht ob irgendwo eine höhle
dran haben aber wir haben auf jeden fall
wenn ihr auch keine hülle drin wäre wäre
es auf jeden fall richtig gut so
wirklich in zweifel zieht ohne hülle und
so was alles nur untergrabe diese reisen
abdecken so grundsätzlich sehe ich hier
glaube ich erst mal keine höhle drin ich
habe hier ist keiner
doch doch doch ich höre lava das lawa
dann war hier wahrscheinlich irgendwann
zombie oder so welches einfach nur da
war hier ist ein bisschen reisen heißen
eisen aber so wirklich irgendwie das
hier so eine richtige höhle ist nicht
sehr interessant da ja gut wir gehen da
raus hier ist wirklich fast einmal durch
geflogen also das ist sonst zieht und
das finde ich auf jeden fall richtig
geil einfach so survival mäßig hier kann
man sich dann hier sondern seine
landschaften diesem bisschen ihr das
ganze in weiß im moment hier kanzlerin
gesehen wird weißte bescheid machte
diesen baum hinweg das ist jetzt eine
gewisse landschaft ein kater sondern
weiß nicht wieso ein häuslein hinbauen
dann hier mit einer rutsche bis zu insel
da hinten dann kann man immer angeln
oder irgendwie sowas nicht einfache
brücke darüber bauen
also das sind echt unmengen an
möglichkeiten auf seiner kleinen insel
mittlerweile in minecraft vorhanden
deswegen ich würde sagen wenn ihr direkt
morgen noch eine sieht vorstellung haben
wollt dann geht einfach den daumen hoch
und ich nehme jetzt auf jeden fall jetzt
direkt weiter auf ein paar ausgesucht
habe ich gucke wie das video hier
ankommt ob ich die dann morgen schon
hochladen oder mir noch ein bisschen
zeit damit lassen kann auch sein dass
ihr mann jan luca macht ein bisschen
pause habe ich denn jetzt
ich will ihn die rückschläge oder drücke
ich mir das immer noch etwa ein bisschen
pause macht aber erst mal was anderes
hier aussieht und so das find ich
irgendwie könnte noch ein bisschen
verändern wenn ich hier unterstehe wird
der himmel total dunkel da hinten obwohl
er eigentlich nur für mich dunkler
werden sollten und welche dann ist
wieder da also das sollte auf jeden fall
nochmal besser werden das ist mal ein
bisschen komisch und her läuft dann ist
der himmel auf einmal dunkel und wieder
hält
keine ahnung aber das ist ein anderes
thema das ich würd sagen gebt dann hoch
wenn ihr mehr wollt schreibt mir auch
zieht es in die kommentare wenn ihr
wollt und dann würde ich sagen sie zu
beschreiben müssten heraus kopieren wir
euch ein kopieren dann sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder rein und